STEPHANIE LIU: Hi everybody.
Welcome to Women Techmakers.
This is Episode 3.
For those of you just tuning in,
this is a series that we
started back in Google I/O
this year and with Susan
Wojcicki's senior leadership
here at Google.
And it was really well
received, so
we're expanding it.
We're really excited to
bring on some really
fabulous guests today.
And I'll be one of your hosts.
I'm Stephanie Liu.
I work on the Developer
Relations team.
Our team is a team of
engineers that helps
third-party developers
be successful in
our developer platforms.
And we're also the team that
helps bring you Google I/O as
well as well Google
Developers Live.
MARY GROVE: Great.
Hi everyone.
My name is Mary Grove, and
I'm the head of Global
Entrepreneurship Outreach
at Google.
Our team runs the Google for
Entrepreneurs program, which
basically includes all of
Google's programs and
partnerships to support startups
and entrepreneurs
around the world.
We have about 50 different
efforts live in over 30
countries, and we're always
looking for ways to get more
engaged and help foster
entrepreneurship in local
communities.
So we're delighted
today to have two
wonderful guests with us.
I'd like to turn it over to let
them introduce themselves.
First is Angela Benton, the
CEO of NewME Accelerator.
ANGELA BENTON: Hi.
I'm Angela Benton.
And as Mary stated, I'm the
CEO of NewME Accelerator,
which is a technology
accelerator/incubator for
underrepresented minorities.
We specifically focus on
African Americans,
Latinos, and women.
And our mission is really just
to accelerate the growth and
the success of those
entrepreneurs.
MARY GROVE: Next we're delighted
to have Stephanie
Palmeri of SoftTech
VC with us today.
Steph, welcome.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Thank you.
Hi everyone.
I'm Stephanie Palmeri.
I'm a venture capitalist
with SoftTech VC.
We are an early stage micro
venture capital fund.
Our current fund is our third
fund and it has $55 million
under management.
And we focus on investing
in early-stage startups,
primarily in consumer,
web, and mobile.
Some of our larger investments
and more well known
investments include companies
like Eventbrite,
fab.com, and Fitbit.
And actually a few months ago,
one of our companies founded
by a female founder, Victoria
Ransom, was actually acquired
by Google and that's Wildfire
Interactive.
I focus specifically on our
next-gen commerce and a lot of
our ed-tech investments, but the
fund really works across a
number of sectors, including
next-generation commerce,
marketplaces, the next wave of
e-commerce, SaaS, and then
mobile services and
infrastructure.
MARY GROVE: Fantastic.
So thanks for kicking us off.
Stephanie, we'd love to explore
a bit about your
career path and journey and
sort of what was your
background experience that led
you into venture capital?
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Sure.
I have--
well, I don't think there's any
one path into venture, and
I have a relatively
nontraditional path.
I actually spent the previous 10
years living and working in
New York City.
And I began my career at
Accenture as a consultant
working with the market
data practice.
And then I wanted to gain
operational experience.
I thought that would actually
be really important.
I enjoyed the advisory service
role, but I really wanted to
get my hands dirty
as an operator.
And I ended up having the
opportunity to join Estee
Lauder in their marketing
department for Clinique,
working really closely with
sales and retail.
And so I spent a few years there
and realized I was not
cut out for large companies.
And in fact, I really
liked working
with smaller companies.
And I then jumped over to an
early startup in New York
building applications for sales
and marketing teams,
essentially enterprise suites
to enable sales forces and
marketing teams to communicate
better and to distribute
content globally.
So I worked really closely
with companies
like SAP and Diageo.
And at that point, I spent
about two years there and
decided to go back to get
my MBA at Columbia
Thought I was going to stay in
New York the rest of my life,
spent two years heavily involved
in the New York scene
and the startup community there
while getting my MBA,
and worked with a seed fund
called NYC Seed, helped them
run an early incubator
in New York City.
And worked with a women-led
high-growth
accelerator called Astia.
And then finally worked at
Lot18, which was an e-commerce
start-up, all while
getting my degree.
And finished up and decided to
move out to California with
just two suitcases.
So ended landing in a role with
SoftTech after quite a
long journey and about two
years of networking and
getting to people
in this space.
And have really had the
opportunity to leverage my
background as both a marketer
but also as a consultant and
someone that had to jump in and
figure out how to solve
problems really quickly
and get to the
heart of a story quickly.
So it's been quite a journey.
MARY GROVE: We're really
glad to have you
out on the West Coast.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Yeah,
I'm glad to be here.
STEPHANIE LIU: Angela, do you
want to tell us a little bit
about your journey and how you
ended up founding NewMe
Accelerator?
ANGELA BENTON: Sure.
I think it's actually--
[LAUGHTER]
ANGELA BENTON: --really similar
to Stephanie's.
I mean, there's no kind of like
direct way that you end
up starting an accelerator.
Actually my background is in
design, so I actually started
out in this industry that
is print publishing
that's around still.
But at the time I was laying out
magazines and everyone was
saying, oh, we're not
going to have any
jobs if you're a designer.
The internet is going to like
kill all of our jobs, and so
you better teach yourself
how to code.
So I taught myself how to code,
and I ended up getting
jobs after that basically
as a front-end engineer.
And I did a lot of side projects
and I worked a lot of
different startups, and I
eventually ended up working at
IAC, which is InterActiveCorp,
for several of their
businesses, lendingtree.com,
realestate.com, And Then also
several different startups
actually within their emerging
businesses unit.
Which is interesting because
it is similar to a startup,
but it's like working at a
very well-funded startup.
[LAUGHTER]
ANGELA BENTON: So that was
quite interesting.
And while I was doing that,
I actually launched a site
called Black Web 2.0 mainly
because I noticed there was
just no coverage of what African
Americans were doing
in the technology space.
And I just started writing
about it from a design
background.
And that site gained community
kind of on its own, and Wayne
and I ended up doing
NewME Accelerator.
That kind of birthed out
of NewME Conference.
And it's been a great,
great journey.
It's kind of one of--
I guess when you think about
kind of what your passion is
and how you got there, I'm
like I would have never
guessed I would have
ended up here.
But it's been great so far.
MARY GROVE: And along those
lines, Angela, you and I first
met almost two years ago now,
and you had just launched
NewMe Accelerator and the
program was just kicking off.
Google's been really proud to
be a supporter and a sponsor
for all three cycles.
How has the reception or the
perception of NewMe changed
over the last three cycles, and
what has the welcome been
both from members of the
community in Silicon Valley
and also nationally
and globally?
ANGELA BENTON: Sure.
It's been overwhelmingly
positive.
I was surprised mainly because I
did not know what to expect.
And especially when you see
something that doesn't exist,
you're like well, why
doesn't it exist?
Is it because people
aren't open to it?
And when Wayne and I started
reaching out to people about
what we wanted to do
it was so amazing.
Everyone was like, yes, I'm
in, yes, I'll mentor, yes,
I'll speak.
And so we were able to
build off a lot of
momentum from that end.
Then, of course, we're in the
CNN documentary last year, and
that was amazing.
And I was talking to someone
the other day, and that
exposure really kind of
accelerated our own growth,
whether we like it or not.
But it's been great because now
we have people literally
not just in the States that
are interested in kind of
self-organizing under our brand
and building community
around it, but we have people
in other countries that are.
And so that's been an
amazing journey.
I'm glad that we've been able to
have you guys on board from
start to now, and I'm looking
forward to continuing that.
STEPHANIE LIU: Yeah.
So me and Mary do a lot of work
with startups and the
startup community as well.
And I think we were just talking
outside about how
amazing it's been the last three
or four years has been
so much interest.
Like from governments to all
these accelerators popping up,
and people wanting to get
involved, mentors and
everything else.
So let's bring it back to the
election because I know much
of our US audience, even our
international audience , is
aware that yesterday you
know we re-elected
President Barack Obama.
And so what's the role of
government in entrepreneurship
and what are the opportunities
there?
Steph, do you want to give
some of your thoughts?
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Yeah, so were
just talking about this
before we walked in, and I
think there's a really
interesting opportunity
right now.
So let's talk about
two things.
First I'd say consumer health,
and a lot of the regulation--
the fact that Obamacare is going
to be around now, and we
know that, is going to really
change the face of how we can
begin to bring more towards
consumerizing health.
I think we're going to see a
lot of opportunity there.
But just broadly speaking
in general around
entrepreneurship and fostering
that within our communities, I
see a lot of things happening
on the ground.
The combination of the JOBS Act,
the proliferation now of
crowdfunding platforms here
within the U.S. Are really
enabling everyday people
to be entrepreneurs.
Not necessarily for high-growth
ventures, but you
can become a small business in
and of yourself a lot more
quickly and to have
access to capital.
And on top of that, we're seeing
this movement in the
maker community and the ability
to produce physical
product again relatively
cheaply and at scale.
And so I think we're going to
see a lot of companies that
are going to be emerging
to provide services and
infrastructure to support this
next wave of entrepreneurship
in the U.S. And I think
it's really exciting.
[INAUDIBLE]
MARY GROVE: I couldn't
agree more.
I think that this is happening
around the world.
We're seeing a lot of
governments asking us, as
Google, what are recommendations
for what
governments.
What are the best practices
for how we create an
environment that is really
conducive to startups,
encouraging them to get off the
ground and really helping
them scale.
And we've run a number of pilots
over the last year in
trying to learn from them.
So in Korea, for example we,
launched something called
Korea Goes Global, which is a
partnership with the Korean
government.
And they've run a competition
and selected the 30 top
companies who've just
gotten started.
They've been incubated in Korea
for three months, and
they're currently spending a
week in London in our Campus
London project and coming out
here to Silicon Valley next
week for a week.
So figuring out how can we
actually pilot some new models
that might be effective and then
use those as examples to
really set the tone for
what's effective.
ANGELA BENTON: Yeah, I'd
actually piggyback off of what
Mary's saying.
I'm seeing that too just here
locally in the States, but
when you're talking about local
governments, it's really global.
I mean in how each governments
can actually
work with each other.
I was talking to someone in
Israel, and they're interested
in learning from Silicon Valley
but also bringing
entrepreneurs from Atlanta and
Detroit there as well.
And so I think if we can
continue to foster that kind
of communication and that global
sense of community
around entrepreneurship, it can
help all local ecosystems.
STEPHANIE LIU: So have you see
anything with crowdfunding,
for example?
You're more at a the very early
stage with Accelerator.
Has that affected anything with
your companies and how
they're approaching funding
versus traditional VCs?
MARY GROVE: Sure.
So not as of yet.
However, there are several
crowdfunding platforms that
continually reach
out to us and--
[LAUGHTER]
MARY GROVE: --want to start
these kind of huge platforms
for our founders that
are coming through.
We only have, I think, a couple
of startups that have
actually tried to use
crowdfunding, but not
necessarily with too
much success yet.
And so many of them are going
the traditional route, if you
could call it that.
STEPHANIE LIU: You still
got a job, Steph.
Don't worry about that.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHANIE PALMERI: You do.
But you know, interestingly
enough, I was going to say,
one of the most recent deals
we've done at SoftTech, and
I'm taking the board seat on
the company, is a company
called Ubooly.
And it's actually a
smartphone-enabled toy.
And it originally began as
a Kickstarter project.
And then later went and joined
the TechStars Boulder class
this summer, and we actually
funded the company coming out
of TechStars Boulder.
So I do you think from time
to time we will see these
projects that will gain traction
and will offer a
broader opportunity where
there's potentially a platform
that goes along with the
physical product of the play.
So it can be a great source of
deal flow, really early deal
flow for us to pay attention
to what's going on.
And then, more broadly, I think
you've got a lot of
products and companies that are
launching after that and
they're going to need
distribution once they go
beyond the crowdfunding
platform.
So I'm starting to see a lot
of early rumblings in the
market around people thinking
through that problem too.
STEPHANIE LIU: Interesting.
MARY GROVE: Very interesting.
So last week we hosted NewMe
Accelerator's Demo Day and
their graduation of their most
class, and we were in the
process of helping them prepare
for their pitches.
I wanted to ask you both what
advice do you have for these
entrepreneurs who are
just getting off the
ground in terms of--
so maybe Stephanie--
what are the key attributes that
you really look for in a
great pitch, a great team?
STEPHANIE PALMERI: I
hope I can say this
word on Google TV.
At SoftTech we have this rule.
It's called the "Three
Asses Rule." [LAUGHTER]
STEPHANIE PALMERI: It's on the
back of our business card and
we're pretty liberal with
cursing a bit at work, so
anyhow let me tell you a little
about the Three Asses.
And it's kind of how we go
about thinking about
deals we look at.
So the most important
of the Three Asses
is a smart-ass team.
And the reality is early stage
investing is really just a
founder, maybe a co-founder,
and potentially a few other
team members.
And that team is the core team
that's going to get that
product and that idea off the
ground during the seed phase
and move on to hopefully Series
A and beyond funding.
So really, at the heart of it,
we're investing in a team.
And what we look for in those
teams are people that have a
combination of vision and
insight into the market that
they want to get into,
potentially some practical
experience, and I'd say at the
end of the day the ability to
walk through walls.
It's founders that just have a
tremendous amount of passion
and gumption and the ability to
execute and make sure they
can make things happen even in
the face of huge obstacles.
The second thing we look for
is a kick-ass product.
A kick-ass is a product that
ideally when companies come to
us they have got at least a
working prototype if not a
launched product, some
customers, even if it's just
people that have played around
with it a little bit, or maybe
even people that are paying
to use the product.
That's awesome.
Doesn't happen a lot,
but it's awesome.
STEPHANIE LIU: Revenue's
always great.
STEPHANIE PALMERI:
Revenue's great.
Never going to complain
when I see a company--
STEPHANIE LIU: [INAUDIBLE] says
there's no problem that
can't be solved with
more revenue.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Definitely.
Exactly.
So a kick-ass product.
And then the final thing look
for is the big-ass market.
And rule of thumb, it's a
billion-dollar market.
And we don't expect our
companies to capture 100% of a
market, and so therefore if you
capture 10% of a big-ass
billion-dollar market, you've
got $100 million in run rate
somewhere down the road,
a few years down the
road, from seed funding.
And so we ask ourselves how
does a company get to a
million in run rate?
Are they going after a large
enough opportunity?
And then I'd say the other
things we think about right
now are what's competition
in that space look like?
So are there other players?
Are they well-funded?
How deep are the pockets?
Or is there still a lot of
opportunity to come in and
capture a substantial share
of that market?
And early stage, we think it
takes about 18 to 24 months of
capital if you're going to raise
a proper seed round to
really make that happen if
you're going after a
venture-backable business.
ANGELA BENTON: So some of the
things we look for, though we
don't have the Three Asses--
[LAUGHTER]
MARY GROVE: --we do look for
a team that's resourceful.
And so we have a set of 10 core
values that we use to
hire for our team internally,
but it actually extends to the
people that we want in
the program as well.
And being creative and
resourceful is
definitely one of them.
We're not too particular on,
oh, we only want to see
technical founders.
That's always great because you
can actually execute on
your idea, but even if you're
not technical, if you're a
business founder, we are hoping
that you learn the
skill to recruit a
technical team.
Generally, we try to make
sure that they're
coming in further along.
Initially we had several
companies that were kind of
just in idea phase, but now we
actually have teams that are
executing well before
they come in.
And then we are basically
helping them refine throughout
the program, which
is a lot of fun.
We do look at markets and things
like that too, but
where we really are focused on
making sure that we get the
right type of entrepreneur
that's for our program.
And then I guess chief among all
the things that we look at
is we want someone who's
comfortable in their own skin.
STEPHANIE LIU: So especially
for the Accelerator aspect,
how much are you-- you know,
you're looking for this
gumption, right, this like
X-factor or whatever.
So what do you hope
to teach them?
You see somebody and
you're like, OK, I
can teach you this.
I can see that you
have the passion.
MARY GROVE: Yeah.
So we're looking for people
who are coachable.
And one of the things
I've learned is
not everybody's coachable.
But yes, so people who are open
to actually learning and
thinking about things
a different way.
Our program is actually
residential, so people live
and work together
for 12 weeks.
It's very, very intense.
STEPHANIE LIU: Like
a reality show.
[LAUGHTER]
MARY GROVE: It is.
It's very, very intense.
And throughout that whole time,
I mean, there's not a
lot of time for personal time.
You're talking to mentors
basically all day, every day.
You're getting so much advice.
One of the great things that I
love about being based in the
Bay Area is so many smart people
condensed in one area.
So you get a lot of really great
information, but we're
looking for people who can take
that information and not
necessarily have it change
totally what they're doing but
that they can make an
educated decision.
Like, this is my long-term goal,
this is where I want to
get to, and this thing that this
person said might apply
to it and so I'm going to
take this into account.
But this person over here
maybe not so much.
So I think that's one of the
things that's hard to do, and
so we're looking for someone
who's open to that but still
is very kind of secure in
what they want to do.
MARY GROVE: Wonderful.
So we talked a lot about
mentorship and the importance
of a network of mentors who have
failed and succeeded and
can sort of help walk
you through that.
For both of you very
accomplished entrepreneurs in
your own right, what are some
of the best pieces of advice
that you've received
from your mentors?
STEPHANIE LIU: I like the
Three Asses thing.
[INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
MARY GROVE: Three Asses Thing.
ANGELA BENTON: And that will
probably be a recurring theme
that comes up throughout
this session.
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE]
ANGELA BENTON: Yes.
One of the best pieces of
advice I've gotten in my
career as a whole is, you know,
I have three kids and I
wanted to try my hand at
entrepreneurship but that's a
scary thing to do.
That's a big risk to take.
And I was talking to someone
about it and the only advice
they said, they were like--
well, I was kind of not
feeling sorry for myself but
like oh, this would be so hard
if I took a leap and did this.
And they were like, so what?
Just do it.
And like that was it.
So what do you say after that?
I'm like, yeah, that's right.
So that's probably my biggest
piece of advice.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: I'd say,
similarly, I had a professor
who was an adjunct at Columbia
who, as I was pursuing venture
after graduation, he was pivotal
in my decision to keep
pursuing that.
And he said to me, look
Stephanie,-- and I think that
the advice holds true for
founders, too-- there will be
many, many people who won't
understand your background and
won't want to take the time to
get to know your story, but it
just takes one.
And the reality is you just
have to believe enough in
yourself to keep going, and I
think constantly reassess
whether or not you're on target
and you're on track,
and take each bit of feedback
you get as one data point.
But ultimately, if you believe
in yourself and you believe
enough in your story it does
just take one person to begin
to believe in you.
And I found that in my own job
search process and as I kind
of move along in my career
at SoftTech.
It just takes one person to
believe in your idea or to
believe in you as an individual,
and then the next
person believes and the
next person believes.
So I think it's you've just got
to take that leap of faith
and believe in yourself.
MARY GROVE: I love that.
I was reflecting on the
question myself.
And for me I think it's about
mission, defining mission, as
well as defining non-goals
for oneself.
Right?
Both for myself and then for the
effort that we're building
here at Google around
entrepreneurship, that's been
really important to have that
laser focus on the mission,
which is very broad, right, to
empower entrepreneurs all over
the world by partnering with
great organizations, by
creating your own programs, but
then also defining what
we're not trying to do.
For example, we're not trying
to create our own incubators
or accelerator programs
at Google.
We're trying to be a platform
that supports and
partners with them.
So equally this is--
my dream is very big, but my
focus is extremely precise.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: We
tell that to our
founders all the time.
Early stage founders have so
many things that they want to
try with their companies.
And they get capital in there
and they want to go in a bunch
of different directions.
The reality is there's usually
one or two key things you have
time to focus on in that first
year or two, and laser focus
gets you to the next phase.
And then you can begin
to do more.
So even if--and it's great
to hear that at large
organizations, you think
the same way.
The laser focus is really what
I think moves the needle.
MARY GROVE: Absolutely.
STEPHANIE LIU: I mean, Mary's
team is basically a startup, I
think, too.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHANIE LIU: She's doing
the whole world
with like three people.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHANIE LIU: So you've still
got to focus, for sure.
MARY GROVE: Trying to
be lean and scrappy.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHANIE LIU: So we're talking
about mentorship, and
so what do you think is the
most important lesson-- is
that also the most important
lesson you've
imparted on your companies?
Do you find that you're saying
the same things over and over?
Or is every case a little bit
different when you go in?
And like I'm going to build this
up in you, so this is the
background I can bring here.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: I mean,
each founder's a unique
snowflake, right?
So each company and each founder
is slightly different,
but there are a lot of
repeatable patterns that you
begin to see.
And so I can look at a subset
of founders and say these
founders are really great at
doing X, Y, and Z, and
potentially their businesses
would improve by
pulling this lever.
But the reality is that you try
to customize your advice
and the relationships you help
those founders build to each
unique case.
But I think the way in which a
firm like mine scales is that
we do begin to recognize
those patterns.
We do one to two deals a month,
right, so we're 40
deals into our current fund.
We'll do another 20, 25.
And so in three years' time,
we'll really begin to
recognize patterns out of that
cohort of companies.
So yeah, you customize what
you're saying, but I think you
begin to recognize these
patterns over
and over again, too.
STEPHANIE LIU: So just to shift
gears a little bit.
Angela, you coming from
a design background.
You have a marketing background,
like kind of a
different background than like
tech, what you might think of
as a tech background, right?
I think something that came out
of the original panel back
around Google I/O was Susan was
saying that what brought
her to tech was the deep
creativity that
was available here.
And that deep creativity you
had, the freedom you had, to
just build something.
And I think that a lot of women
are sort of put off by
tech because they see it as
maybe too sterile or they
don't identify with
the culture.
So I guess I wanted your guys's
thoughts on the role of
creativity in entrepreneurship
and technology.
And maybe talk to some of these
women and tell them like
what kind of experience
you're having here.
ANGELA BENTON: Yeah, so one of
the biggest things that I tend
to tell people about the
technology industry is I
really just think it's like
an image problem.
[LAUGHTER]
ANGELA BENTON: Like people think
that you're like a nerdy
white guy in a room or in a
basement coding and that's it.
And that's what technology
looks like.
But it's really creative.
You do get your hands dirty.
I love what I do because I not
only get to build NewMe as its
own startup, but I
get to help other
people with their startups.
And it's a lot of
tangible work.
I mean, my design background,
while I don't design as much
and I don't code as much
anymore, a lot of the way how
I think is kind of
design thinking.
You know what I mean?
And so really like how we're
thinking about executing on
the next cycle or how we're
thinking about scaling, all of
that really kind of goes back
into the creativity that I
learned like in Design
Theory 101.
STEPHANIE PALMERI:
I totally agree.
It's a little bit of
an image problem.
Not only is it creative, but
I think the reality is the
stereotypes we have around tech
are, again, sitting in
that room, dark, working
alone and solo.
And what we don't talk
enough about is
that it's about teams.
And it's about teams working
together to create and build
products and to test
and try ideas.
And that as you move up within
that team, there's opportunity
to take on leadership roles
and management roles.
And you're potentially not in
the daily grind of writing
code anymore.
Now suddenly you're
a leader as well.
And you can be a leader on a
small team or a large team,
but I think the reality is we
don't talk enough about the
progression of what those
careers look like.
And then how you can take
something in that career and
apply it towards something
that's potentially not as
technical but more
management-related.
Right?
So I've always been
interested in the
intersection between the two.
You know, I studied management
information systems and
marketing in college and so kind
of continued to always
find a way to merge technology
and marketing
throughout my career.
And I'd agree that I don't think
it's talked enough about
about what career diversity
looks like.
And you think about oh, an
engineer or a computer science
major does X, Y, and Z and sits
in that dark room and
they really don't.
ANGELA BENTON: Yeah particularly
as it relates to
entrepreneurship, though.
It's like there's all of this
training and activity around
building the product, finding
out who the customer is,
launching, scaling.
There's not enough information
around actually developing
leadership skills.
And I didn't realize that until
we started to get a lot
of alumni out of the program,
and they're coming back to us
with questions and they're
really management and
leadership questions.
MARY GROVE: Very interesting.
So the other spin on the
question of diversity and the
importance of diversity in teams
or in the ecosystem, the
industry in general.
I would love to get both
of your thoughts.
Clearly, Angela, your program is
to foster female founders,
African American,
Latino founders.
And Stephanie, you talked about
investing in startups
that have female founders
as well.
So talk to us about the state of
the landscape, and how has
it evolved over the
last few years.
What do you think are effective
mechanisms to really
help foster diversity among
teams and within companies?
ANGELA BENTON: Sure.
Well there's been so
much activity.
For me I think back to 2007,
when I couldn't find anything
and it's like I just started
this little blog.
So for me I'm like, whoa, it's
all of this stuff now.
[LAUGHTER]
ANGELA BENTON: And so that's
really, really great.
That's really great to see.
I'm hoping what the
future landscape
includes is kind of--
I guess to piggyback off of what
I just said, there seems
to be this sequential number
of steps that need to be
integrated where maybe you're
in a pre-incubator and then
you go to an accelerator and
then you get funded.
But I feel like all the activity
is great, but it
needs to be a little bit more
kind of cohesive so that we're
really making the kind
of impact to change
what things look like.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: All right,
let me see if-- can you repeat
the question again?
MARY GROVE: Sure.
I guess we were talking
about diversity.
And then so there's
diversity--
STEPHANIE PALMERI: We see a
lot of diversity, right?
MARY GROVE: You do.
I'd love to--
STEPHANIE PALMERI: We do.
MARY GROVE: So among the
startups that you've met, for
example, have you noticed any
noticeable trends in teams
that are [INAUDIBLE]
and women [INAUDIBLE].
STEPHANIE PALMERI: So first off,
one thing I notice is a
lot of times I'm the first
female investor that a lot of
these companies meet with.
And that's particularly exciting
when a female founder
walks in the door.
And the conversation sometimes
completely changes.
And we just step aside from
talking about the business to
kind of talking about some of
those dynamics as well.
And I think that's exciting.
It's exciting for me to be at a
place in the industry where
I can have that kind of
connection to a founder.
Whether or not I end up doing
the deal, I am able to
personally connect.
Because I know what's it's like
to walk in the room and
potentially be the only
one sometimes.
We actually meet with quite a
female founders, and I think
some of that is the fact that
I'm a woman in our firm and we
have a relatively diverse
firm to begin with.
And we're early stage and so
there's a lot of women that
are sort of getting into
starting companies these days
as opposed to women that have
been leading companies looking
for follow-on funding.
So that makes a lot of sense.
The other thing I've noticed,
though, is that previously a
lot of the female founders that
were coming to SoftTech
were building companies not
necessarily focused on women.
So we've seen definitely a shift
towards female founders
building companies
focused on women.
And particularly within the
next-gen gen commerce space.
I'll give you an example of a
deal that we did recently is a
company called True&Co.
And it's an e-commerce
play around a fit
algorithm to fit bras.
So kind of applying, in a sense,
the home trial model to
ship five bras, see
how they fit.
And the interesting thing about
that conversation was
that when Michelle Lam, the
founder, came to us to pitch
the idea, she and I didn't
have to spend 20 minutes
talking about what
the issue was.
[LAUGHTER]
MARY GROVE: What's the problem
you're trying to solve?
STEPHANIE PALMERI: What's
the problem
you're trying to solve?
I understood the problem.
And I think the reality is
there's a lot of women that
are starting companies these
days that are focused on
problems that women have.
And then female investors can
kind of get to the core of
that problem much quicker
and move on to
the meat of the business.
And I think that's exciting.
I do, however, think just in
general, the lower barrier you
talked about, the need to not
necessarily be an engineer to
launch a company, there
is a lower barrier--
it's easier to get an idea into
testing and to determine
feasibility.
And so you don't necessarily
need to have a technical
background.
I think you do hit a wall
eventually if you don't have a
technical team in
place, though.
MARY GROVE: Um-hmm.
Makes sense.
STEPHANIE LIU: So I had another
question based on you
said that you don't use design
as much anymore.
And there was something that
came up which is that there
are a lot of companies--
the barrier to entry is low.
So it's pretty crowded space.
So more and more marketing
and design--
who happen to be the two experts
we have over here--
are now like big
differentiators.
Especially in early stage, when
you're trying to fight
your way out of this like
pit of [INAUDIBLE].
STEPHANIE PALMERI:
So you're saying
it's all about execution.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHANIE LIU: So what advice
could you give a startup out
there about either looking at
their design or looking at
their marketing techniques to
differentiate themselves?
MARY GROVE: Hmmm.
Let me put my creative
hat back on.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHANIE PALMERI:
I'll dive in.
You know, I work with
the early stage
founders all the time.
And the reality is it's focusing
on those one or two
core metrics that are to move
the needle for your business.
So what is that measurement
that you need to focus on?
Every decision you make about
your product, about your
marketing, about your hiring,
about your spending, is all
going back to those core metrics
that are going to move
the needle and get enough either
traction, customer
engagement.
So it's either customer
acquisition, maybe user
engagement, retention, it
potentially could be revenue,
but the reality is early stage,
it's identifying what
those core metrics are and
making really tough decisions
that you're focusing
on those metrics.
ANGELA BENTON: Yeah.
From a design perspective, with
HTML5 and CSS3, I mean
there's so much flexibility now
in what you can actually
execute and how you actually
execute it.
And so I think there is
a lot of opportunity.
The issue with design then
becomes how do you become the
most creative person?
How do you make sure
that nothing you do
exists right now?
And I think that--
[LAUGHTER]
ANGELA BENTON: --that's an issue
that designers have.
I know I've had that issue
several times.
But one of the things that
I was actually talking to
someone about is, again, back
to this idea of being
collaborative and it's
not someone solo
working in a room.
So how do you get other
creatives around you, but the
diversity of creatives.
Maybe it's not just
all designers.
Maybe it's someone who is a
videographer or someone who
does something else, does
signage or whatever.
And taking all of those elements
so that you're not
just designing really kind
of for like a 2D space.
With HTML5--
I just saw this, oh, it
was Square's site.
Oh my gosh, I was just on their
site and like literally
it was HTML5, but it was
basically like a 3D type of
experience.
So that's my advice.
MARY GROVE: Nice.
[LAUGHTER]
MARY GROVE: We have an audience
question, shifting
gears to our moderator
page for Stephanie.
And Stephanie, it says one
of the most difficult--
STEPHANIE PALMERI:
Thanks, John.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHANIE PALMERI: He warned
me he was going to do this.
[LAUGHTER]
MARY GROVE: Our viewers may
benefit from this advice.
The question is that one of the
most difficult challenges
in starting hardware-based
startups is that it's such a
capital-intensive business
to scale
beyond initial prototype.
And Stephanie, how does that
affect the way you evaluate
potential investments,
especially at the seed level?
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Well John,
that's a great question.
We've now done two investments
in a physical product.
The first was Fitbit, which our
founder, Jeff Clavier, did
several years ago, I
think back in 2008.
And I think that may have
been pre-prototype.
And the second one we've done,
which is Ubooly, which I
mentioned earlier.
And Carly and her team actually
had a physical
product being manufactured.
It was pretty much ready
to ship by the
time we did the deal.
So I think a lot's changed in a
few years, and the products
are very different products.
But the reality is it
is a lot harder.
The capital requirements for a
physical product are a lot
more intense.
I think to begin with, certainly
crowdfunding
platforms showing some initial
customer interest is one good
way to kind of demonstrate to
later stage seed investors
that there might be some
interest in your product.
But that being said, I think
there will be certain products
that will resonate with
certain investors.
And part of our job is to do
enough diligence to understand
what does your model look like,
what does it actually
take to get a product produced,
and in what volume
and what kind of traction will
be significant to get you to
the next phase.
So it may take a slightly
larger seed round.
It may take a little bit more
patience in terms of capital.
But essentially, when we think
about investing in physical
products, we're not just
investing in physical products.
The physical products we're
investing in have a much
broader platform.
Usually they're a
hardware-software play.
Both Fitbit and Ubooly really
are software plays.
And so we're looking--
you know, the physical
product is great.
Get it there.
Show that you can build it.
Demonstrate how you
will build it.
But really what we're looking
for as venture capitalists is
a product that goes beyond the
physical product and creates a
platform and an ecosystem
around it.
Hope that answers your
question, John.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHANIE LIU: That makes sense
given that "soft" is in
the SoftTech.
In the name.
STEPHANIE PALMERI:
Yeah, exactly.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Yeah I
think that's a French
derivative there, but yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE]
STEPHANIE LIU: So, speaking of
hardware, going off that a
little bit.
So in general, though, when
you guys are looking at
companies to invest in, as
you're building out the
portfolio, are there certain
markets, specific markets,
you're trying to hit?
Like you're trying to get
a company that sort of
[INAUDIBLE]?
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Sometimes.
That's a great question--
I mean it's a split
between the two.
So we deal in pretty
high volume.
So one to two deals a month
is a lot of deals.
There's certainly times where
we sit down as a firm or as
individual investment
professionals within the firm
and say, I'm really interested
in exploring and looking for
opportunities within
this space.
And we may make an effort to try
to meet a lot of companies
in a short period of time that
focus on a particular area.
But the reality is we just have
a lot of inbound deal
flow through our network, and
so we consider opportunities
that kind of fit with the
thesis, but we also have the
opportunity to experiment
and do things
outside of the thesis.
Really good example, I think, of
that is we've recently done
three deals in the last year
in education technology.
And a year ago, we had zero
investments in ed-tech.
And we did our first investment
in a company called
ClassDojo, and ClassDojo sort
of opened our mind to the
opportunity within education
technology.
And later on we've moved on to
do an investment in a company
called Top Hat Monocle, and then
finally Clever, which we
just announced a
few weeks ago.
And so I would say sometimes
we go out and look for a
particular space.
Sometimes a space sort of comes
knocking at our door,
and it opens our eyes to broader
opportunities within
that sector.
STEPHANIE LIU: Yeah, so it's
interesting because from the
accelerator perspective, you
expect the pivots to be kind
of like fast and furious.
And you might be in a totally
different space
than when you started.
So what approach do you guys
take to building a good-- like
you said, you talked about
this "Big Brother" living
together for 12 weeks thing.
So how do you build
a good dynamic?
How much of that is in the back
of your mind when you're
looking at applications?
ANGELA BENTON: So our
applications have some
behavioral questions that we
kind of infuse in there so it
can kind of give us a sense of
who this person is, if they
fit our core values,
if they would be a
good fit for our program.
But kind of to piggyback on what
you said, I mean, we are
kind of not necessarily vertical
agnostic, but we're
just getting a lot of different
type of companies.
So for instance, this cycle we
had a lot of education of
companies that applied, and so
that was like reflected in the
founders that we
actually chose.
And so that added an interesting
dynamic that we
had at least two education
companies in this past cycle
who are not necessarily
competing but they're in the
same space, and so that hadn't
kind of happened before.
But the dynamic, I would say
we've been lucky to not have
any major issues because
of the--
STEPHANIE LIU: Like direct
competitors.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHANIE PALMERI: No one's
fighting it out.
[LAUGHTER]
ANGELA BENTON: No direct
competitors.
And I would say as we're
looking through the
applications it's not
something that we're
consciously aware of like, oh
my god, these two companies
are really interesting so they
can't live together.
It's just something that
happens kind of more--
STEPHANIE LIU: It's
more organically.
ANGELA BENTON: --organic,
yeah.
MARY GROVE: So to that then,
Angela, can you talk to us
about some of the shining stars
that have come out of
NewMe Accelerator.
Either this season or from
previous seasons.
ANGELA BENTON: So AgLocal is a
favorite of everyone's, which
is great, and basically what
they're developing is a
marketplace that connects
farmers who are growing or
raising sustainably-fed meat
and connecting them with
restaurants and consumers.
But this last cycle that
we had, we have--
they did a pivot, so I always
want to call them Whoorli, but
their new name is Derbywire.
And they are kind of near and
dear to me because what
they're building is a
marketplace for creatives.
And I can't wait to put it on
my tablet later tonight when
it's in the App Store because
I've been trying to--
I take all these really great
pictures on Instagram but you
can't monetize that
right as of yet.
And so it should
be interesting.
I can't wait to be like
user number one.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: So it's
launching tonight
in the Droid Store?
ANGELA BENTON: In the Android
Store, so it's
Derbywire, so yes--
[LAUGHTER]
ANGELA BENTON: --happy
about that.
Picture Menu is also
one that's great.
He actually just got his app in
to the Apple iPhone store.
Yeah, oops, sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
ANGELA BENTON: And Kairos is
something that's a little bit
different because they're
an enterprise play.
So they're not consumer and
they're not B2B, and they have
a lot of traction
with JCPenney.
They're actually testing their
roll-out in several of their
stores, and basically what they
do is they use facial and
object recognition to allow
companies to manage your
businesses better, whether
it's using it as a way to
check in as a time clock.
So those are--
MARY GROVE: Quite
a range there.
[LAUGHTER]
ANGELA BENTON: It is.
It is.
But again, if you're like really
creative, I'm like oh,
I don't have to do all this
other stuff because all these
people are doing it.
And I can help them out.
MARY GROVE: Very cool.
Steph, shining stars?
STEPHANIE PALMERI:
Shining stars.
I'm addicted to a company we
have called Poshmark, which is
a marketplace for women's
clothing.
So second sell something-- take
a photo of something in
my closet, upload it on my phone
really quickly, and list
it to the market immediately.
ANGELA BENTON: I need that.
[INAUDIBLE]
STEPHANIE PALMERI: I open this
up several times a day and
spend way too much time on it
to the extent where I'm
worried that the founders are
like, what are you doing?
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Did your
shoes get listed?
So that's a fun one and that's
one that I really-- but I
think the interesting thing
about that business is it kind
of goes off the collaborative
consumption theme.
So it's recycled.
It's sharing items, or
reselling, and exchanging
items from my closet
to your closet.
And we're seeing a
lot of interest
obviously in that area.
Yeah.
STEPHANIE LIU: So we talked
about-- we touched on
e-commerce fashion and, well,
with bras and reusing or open
up my closet kind of thing and
edu, so do you see more women
entering these spaces?
I'm just curious.
[INAUDIBLE].
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Yeah.
Absolutely.
I mean I think the reality is
you have a lot of women that
have industry background,
whether it's fashion, media,
things that are applicable
to the business
side of these startups.
And the lower barrier to
produce, to get a site up and
running or an app up and running
has enabled these
founders, and in many cases
these women, to, at a pretty
low cost, begin to test some of
these concepts and launch
businesses.
And to compete potentially with
large players that are
burdened by physical retail.
So I think what's going on in
commerce right now is quite
interesting.
We've done a number of
investments in this space.
But I think it's also a great
opportunity for women.
Although I hate to discourage
women from starting companies
outside of those spaces, but I
think absolutely, if you're a
female and you have built a
passion as well as a potential
professional background in these
sectors, there's a lot
of opportunity there.
ANGELA BENTON: Yeah, several of
our founders have industry
expertise kind of turn-tech
entrepreneurs because of that,
which actually makes them
more appealing to us.
So Carolina with Spriggle, who
they were just in the last
cycle, that was here last week,
has experience as an
educator, had launched a charter
school that has helped
thousands of families.
And now she's basically taking
her experience to basically
distribute science and education
toys to moms kind of
using the Mary Kay model.
And Rachel Brooks from Citizen
Made is also participating in
the e-commerce and maker's
market like a lot of your
founders are.
STEPHANIE LIU: Very cool.
MARY GROVE: So thinking about
the path from accelerator to
fully-launched company to
investment, do you see,
Stephanie, any-- do you tend to
see among investments that
you make a prevalence of those
companies having gone through
an incubator or accelerator
or--
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Majority of
our companies don't come out
of an accelerator.
We certainly do invest in
companies that do come out of
accelerators.
In any given month, we may do
one deal coming out of an
accelerator, but we certainly
don't have a bias
one way or the other.
I think at the end of the day,
we're looking for just really
strong founders with ideas
that have traction.
And I think the decision to
participate in an accelerator
program is a very personal
decision for a founding team.
I think it can provide
a lot of resources.
I think for first-time
entrepreneurs, it provides
access to networks that
they maybe didn't
have exposure to before.
But as we look to back second-
and even third-time founders,
it's really rare to see those
founders coming through an
accelerator.
[INAUDIBLE]
STEPHANIE PALMERI: So it's
really looking at--
for us, we're looking at the
company and the prospect for
the company.
The accelerator bit
comes second.
But I think at the end of the
day, there's just been a
tremendous amount of interest
in that area.
And I think if anything, it's
producing a lot of companies,
and it's my job to kind of
filter through and say what
are the best companies
regardless of where the source
is coming from that are going
to get to the next stage?
STEPHANIE LIU: So as kind of
closing thoughts, what do both
of you think we need
to be doing?
What does everyone need to be
doing in the investment
community, in the startup
community, entrepreneurship
community, to get
more diversity?
What's the call to action now
for everyone out there?
ANGELA BENTON: I think the
biggest call to action is
everybody is busy, so it's
really just being
conscious about it.
People aren't willfully
exclusive, it's just people
are busy and they have
things to do.
And so it's like when you're
looking in your networks your
networks tend to be made up of
people who are like you, and
so it does actually take more
effort to be more inclusive.
And so just being conscious of
it would be a big thing.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: I think it
takes an effort on behalf of
both women and men.
And I think as women we do
have more females in our
network, so it is about I'm
a woman who's on an upward
trajectory, I'm going to bring
two more women along with me.
Right?
And the women above me, I look
to to help pull me along too.
But I also don't exclude myself
in just looking for
women to provide that.
The reality is the majority of
the folks in the space that we
all are in are males today.
And that only changes if both
men and women are there to
kind of get a seat
at the table.
And I think it's naturally
beginning to happen.
I think we're just seeing trends
whether you're looking
at more board seats and even
Fortune 500 executives
naturally, the number is
slowly creeping up.
The same is true for the number
of female founders
getting funded.
The same is true for the number
of females entering the
[INAUDIBLE]
community.
But I think if we're a little
bit more actively involved
about asking women
to take a seat--
you know what I'm excited for?
I'm excited for the day where no
one invites any of us to do
a panel about women.
Right?
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE]
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Where
suddenly we're just part of
the conversation.
And it's not oh, wait, we need
to remember to invite a woman
to join us.
And I think we'll get there
within maybe not my
generation, but I think
we're on the way.
STEPHANIE LIU: What do you guys
think of Dave McClure's
challenge to get more women
involved in $5,000 seed-level
funding and really put money
where your mouth is?
Do you think that's going to be
an effective way to bring,
like you said, a lot more people
to the table, and make
more people aware of it?
ANGELA BENTON: I think it'll
definitely make more people
aware of it.
Also, I think, while the barrier
to entry is low to
begin with, I think having
$5,000 will also kind of let
people take that leap and
it's less of a risk.
Even though it's not much, it's
still less of a risk.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: I think
it's important to have a
conversation about having more
women begin to give back.
But what I would say to any
investor is you invest in the
best companies and the best
people, regardless of gender.
I would like to see more female
angels around the table
so that there's more women
thinking about investing and
making investment decisions.
And potentially growing a
portfolio at a small stage so
that they can potentially
move on and do it more
professionally.
But there's a really big
difference between being a
professional investor and
casually making small angel
investments.
But I think any attention that's
put on this space right
now is relatively positive
attention, so I'm
happy to see it.
And I would encourage more women
to think about how they
can get involved in the
community, whether it's
mentorship, investing, or
actually starting a company.
STEPHANIE LIU: Mary,
any final thoughts?
What do you think
about this one?
MARY GROVE: Yeah, we've
thought a lot about
entrepreneurship and the
cultural values of Silicon
Valley and what makes the
ecosystem here thrive so much.
And I think we've been fortunate
to work really in
every region of the world.
And I think that
entrepreneurship is absolutely
thriving, not just in the
Valley, not just across the
country, but truly
across the world.
It's more vibrant than ever.
We've talked a lot about
the barriers to entry
being lower than ever.
I think it's truly that time,
and for all of us who are
thinking about programs or
partnerships or developing
these outreach programs to have
an eye for inclusion in
all senses of the word,
geographic, gender, otherwise.
I think it really does take
a community and takes a
concerted effort, and
I'm similarly
very bullish and hopeful.
STEPHANIE LIU: Well thank
you guys so much
for joining us today.
I think this was a great chat.
I feel like my next career is
going to be talk show host.
LAUGHTER]
STEPHANIE LIU: Like "The
View." I love this.
I love this right here.
ANGELA BENTON: We have
a good dynamic.
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE]
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Next time
we need the table with all
four of us all in one
tiny little place.
[LAUGHTER]
MARY GROVE: Yeah, thank you
guys for joining us.
ANGELA BENTON: Thanks
for having me.
STEPHANIE LIU: So and--
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Thank you.
STEPHANIE LIU: --thank you for
joining us and tuning in.
Please remember to tune in
tomorrow because we'll have
Diane Greene, who's the former
CEO of VMware as well as she's
on the board of directors
for Google.